today's questions from Ben and Ohio is
it okay to wait to attack our debt for
two months until our weekend vacations
are over or should we cancel them and
attack now I don't know what a weekend
vacation is you've got things planned to
do on the weekend
that you're going to travel and spend
money while you're in debt I guess
that's what it is
I bet Ben you're a grown person you can
do whatever you want to do but I can
tell you this dude until you decide that
this matters more than anything else
you're not gonna get out of debt you can
wander into debt you can't wander out
the more radical you get the deeper you
sacrifice the more likely you are to get
out and the faster you'll get out the
higher the probability and the faster
the speed you can see the more fired up
you get the more angry you get the more
sick and tired of being sick and tired
you get the deeper you're willing to
sacrifice your life so what this tells
me is that you're probably not ready to
get out of debt yet or you're gonna wade
in and it's gonna take you a long time
to get as fired up as I'm talking about
the young couple just got off the phone
with they got married they make 115
thousand dollars a year they came home
from their honeymoon you know what they
did nothing that's what they did nothing
for the first year of marriage they did
nothing except get out of that nothing
think about it but they paid off seventy
five thousand dollars of debt in 13
months makin hundred fifteen thousand
the job just hear those numbers it's
unbelievable
they did nothing there's no room in that
budget there is no eating out in that
budget there's no whatever a weekend
vacation is they didn't have one so
they're you know the way you get out of
that is you get angry at the debt and
you get sick and tired of being sick and
tired we make too much money to be this
broke
I'm tired of the stress in our life I'm
tired of not knowing if my kids are
gonna go to college
I'm tired if I'm gonna have to retire
and order the cookbook 72 ways to
prepare Alpo and love it I'm tired of
being broke I'm tired of being normal
which sucks
I'm tired of that when you get tired
that's when you say I've had it and
that's when you change and you won't
have to ask me about whether you go on
vacation or not because it won't even be
an option the good news is I'm getting
nicer I know some of you think I'm a
jerk but I mean actually getting nicer I
actually had a couple I was coaching
one-on-one about ten years ago and they
were from Texas and good night good
morning America CBS this morning wanted
to follow them through the process so
they flew down to Texas we did we filmed
a segment of them starting the process
then we filmed another one and we walked
with them through the segments the third
segment they were in New York and we're
sitting in the studio at CBS the Early
Show doing the CBS Morning Show that CBS
Early Show and the woman tells me
they've gone on vacation I made her cry
on national television nicer than I used
to be but I had poured so much into
these characters to get them out of debt
and right in the middle of it she just
bows up and goes on vacation well I've
got them on national television trying
to drag their butts out of debt so I
yeah by the time she was done she was
crying and it's like yeah so now I'm a
jerk
okay well no you're stupid that's what
it is oh my gosh unbelievable so now I
don't think I don't know what a weekend
vacation is but it doesn't sound like
it's something that you need to be doing
it sounds like you need to be work
over time but Ben you're an adult you
get to choose this shows about giving
you the instruction of the process that
tens of millions of families have used
to get out of debt and that's what I'm
here to share with you and the process
includes the attitude the process
includes your vision the process is not
just mechanical if this was a math
problem you would have already solved it
you wouldn't be listening to the show
because we know what the math is we know
how to do math means sixth grade math
I'll get you out of debt crap fourth
grade map I'll get an Apple get you out
of debt then where you went to school
but it's really it's addition and
subtraction you increase the income and
decrease the outgo how hard is this I
mean if you can't do it you're eligible
to be in Congress but that's all you do
but that requires this tremendous change
in the person in your mirror and you
have to get fired up about it until you
have a really big oomph of visceral
reaction to these kinds of things you're
you're probably not gonna get out of
that it has to happen it has to be this
big thing there's really no middle
ground you can't like sort of kind of
ish do this stuff so that that's really
a big part of the equation that's what
I'm spending so much time on it